all right someone sent me this from ig
get off that
get up
i've been kissing you you've been
sucking
you've been sucking
yo just get off that right now
[Music]
why are you cheating on me answer the
question michael answer the question
why not answer the question
just get up he caught
his girl in a car with another man yeah
just leave
take your hell
just
why are you cheating just sleep
you knowing why she cheating on you will
not solve
anything
can you appreciate something he's
yelling why are you cheating on me the
other nigga's dick is still inside oh
yeah
so that's what it does he's just
imagining he's like
doing that slow thrust
why are you cheating on me
this dick
why you cheating on me right here [ __ ]
i feel this pain it's [ __ ] up it's
really it really is [ __ ] up but and
then the guy can say like yeah don't ask
there's nothing rational that's going to
come out of this no more do this hurt
and i get that yeah he's you know he's
just discovered something that's really
painful and you know when you devote
yourself to somebody and you sacrifice
so much and to find out they betrayed
you it's like such a shocking thing i
could understand like the outburst it's
not how i would react personally but i
understand how someone can get there
right yeah you know you don't know what
kind of situation they have in terms of
kids promises they've made so there's
probably a lot there but this man get
mad and yell and he's like
why and she's like cause i don't love
you damn did you she said that didn't
hear her she said that i said i just
heard just leave she said you just leave
he's like why are you cheating on me
because i don't love you leave i don't
[ __ ] love you you just
imagine he just leaves like where were
we now
well
if a girl's kid you catch a girl
cheating and she don't even get off the
dick for you you know she don't give a
[ __ ] about you she's not even she's not
even she's like oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] she's
not even facing no she's over the
shoulder dude
hello
i'm busy leaving shut the door shut the
door
shut the doors
not even turning for front for you
that's mad
that's crazy what's crazy if she grabs
her [ __ ] like this
what like she's covering up she's like
oh she didn't cover up no
she didn't cover up there's nobody
imagine
her titties were out everywhere but
here's what's crazy
what
this is the craziest part about this
whole story for me you ready
go ahead
this [ __ ] uploaded the video
he uploaded but that doesn't kill you
he won't expose her that's why that's
why he did that but imagine getting
[ __ ] over and you'll be like i'm gonna
post my embarrassment that's not what he
sees that's not what he's clearly not
because he's is i'm gonna expose her
this is the type of [ __ ] she does
my thing is rough there's another man's
inside joe curl oh yeah keep that [ __ ]
yeah take that to the grave
this should never happen deuces
she did the over the shoulder she had no
shame it was one thing if she was like
oh my god i'm sorry i'm sorry man that
didn't happen but that's the thing they
want to show there's a bunch of things
that happen but there's a bunch of
videos like that you know there's
another video that was going on and
people sent us that video we didn't
comment on it there's a guy he he's
giving a present to a girl he's like oh
thank you
yeah yeah i understand what that but but
yeah but people do that you understand
yeah like they when they get they do
they we're in the era of exposing [ __ ]
so whenever someone does bad or you
catch them on video you expose them yeah
but it doesn't matter how it makes you
feel it's how she looks now i mean
listen you know she did what she did but
he yeah i mean don't make him look good
too i wouldn't i wouldn't post it i
wouldn't post it i couldn't post it
that's cringe my girl my girl getting
digged down by another dude and they
don't even take a break after i catch
them [ __ ]
that's cold
that's cold and if and if you're going
if you yeah if you're gonna leave me i'm
gonna like yeah that's just woof
wooh
that couldn't be me
hanging around my [ __ ] and be like
damn
like that's my homie
and he filmed that and upload that but
[ __ ] put that down
put that down am i wrong to say that put
it down yo bro
put it down i get you mad at her and i
get you want to get back at her or
whatever put it down but believe me this
don't look good oh man you're going to
be viral for the wrong reasons
[Music]
but you know who's not going to be
higher on who's happy well him because
no the nigga's inside her
we don't know if he's viral or not oh
he's not in the video well her piece is
viral
yeah he's just got to he's got some
[ __ ] and just sat back yeah he's not in
the video no no no i'll say this any guy
who's like caesar grows in a
relationship don't don't don't do it
okay because you saw that outburst from
that dude it could turn violent very
fast
that's why i never [ __ ] around with
married people or people in
relationships if anyone told me they
were
i'd walk away because the thing is dudes
don't act normal no when they get
cheated on like i want to talk about a
situation again violent violent yeah
like with dudes it escalates they're
like
the girl told me she was single oh we
got involved later come to find out a
year later this dude's trying to like
take my what you're coming at me for
yeah you [ __ ] my wife i'm like bro i
don't [ __ ] with nobody you were not even
with her no
dude it's just a bit cray cray yes but i
know he suspected that we worked yeah
and so that's where it went crazy right
yeah she ended up meeting him afterwards
but his head
right so
to me i'm sitting back and i'm like bro
you this crazy and nothing happened
imagine if [ __ ] had whenever i asked
people it's like 95 of [ __ ]
when i asked them yo you you catch a
girl what do you do i'm beating the guy
up beating the guy up always 95
90 a hundred percent of the people
you're gonna have because i be the guy i
don't do [ __ ] there's nothing i can do i
know it's how i'm wired or whatever i'm
wired differently i see my girl went to
bed with another dude
well that was not the time to talk
because you busy
and there's nothing much i could do
i mean and there's not much i could say
i mean if you got to say something i get
it it's like you have all this fury and
this anger in you in that moment you
can't take it on your girl because
you're gonna be a woman beater yeah but
you can beat the dude and still get away
with it yeah you know but no because
oftentimes you end up catching the
charge for assault yeah the woman then
leaves you and takes her place or takes
her home or takes her property so now
you're in jail but you got to lose a lot
of money and you lost the girl you're in
jail with a charge [ __ ] and if there's a
kid involved well good luck adding
access to that kid you ain't you in jail
with a charge and you got to pay child
support wow that's that's a lot of elves
already wow and here's the thing if you
really think about it the woman is who
did you dirty it wasn't a dude it wasn't
a dude here's a hypothetical for you
okay if you don't understand why i'm
saying it's not to do
if you got a girl right
and you catch her
online
let's say she's messaging a bunch of
guys and they're never replying but
she's like hey i wanna i wanna chomp on
your dick and all this other stuff right
and you find those messages and say hey
come on please come over and nobody
replies how would you feel would you not
feel still betrayed
wow you're going to go on the guys all
the guys look at the guy all the guys
why because
the truth is she's the one who betrayed
your trust she's the one who's out there
acting crazy and then choosing to do
this stuff right to get mad at the dude
just for replying he's not the one who
has a trust agreement with you no you
got what i'm saying she that dude has
nothing to do with you right so so to me
it's like i never understood why the
anger always goes there like yo get mad
at your girl have have that energy for
her i'm not saying beat her up that's
stupid don't fight with anybody in those
kind of situations but i always find it
stupid when people say i'm gonna fight
the dude i just don't yeah i'm not yeah
i'm not with that but anyways
all this to say if you're in that
situation guys don't get involved with
these people and if you catch a girl and
you film it
maybe it's not a good idea to film put
it down or to upload it put it down but
i digress maybe i'll feel it i don't
know if it's because i'm not so much on
my phone like that yeah but yeah if
[ __ ] will be filming everything
everything put it online they got to
prove it
didn't happen it's okay to tell you not
document it yeah you know oh yeah not
all your losses have to be like yeah
you don't have to upload that stuff i
don't necessarily put my wins i don't
put my losses yeah i got people
messaging me like and they're sending me
videos of like their baby mom's like
look how crazy this [ __ ] i'm like bro
that's your baby mom why are you sending
me this video you want me to cover it
you want me to put your baby mom on
blast it's like you told me to put your
baby mom on blast so y'all have a huge
situation with youtube the family the
courts like why would you invite this
kind of dramas i always delete those
videos it's like
and it says a lot about you too you
chose her yeah that's your choice yeah
you stayed there but anyways maybe y'all
feel different let us know in the
comments below what do you guys think
about this whole situation
put it down just put it down